what i want to do in this video is to
see whether the power rule is giving us
results that at least seem reasonable
this is by no means a proof of the power
rule but at least it'll it'll
will feel a little bit more comfortable
using it so let's say that f of x f of x
is equal to
x
the power rule tells us that f prime of
x is going to be equal to what
well x is the same thing as x to the
first power so n is implicitly 1 right
over here so we bring the 1 out front
it'll be 1 times x to the 1 minus 1
power so it's going to be 1 times x to
the 0 power x to the 0 is just 1 so it's
just going to be equal to 1. now does
that make conceptual sense if we
actually try to visualize these
functions so let's
let me draw let me actually try to graph
these functions
so
that's my y
axis this is my x-axis and let me graph
y equals x
so y is equal to f of x here so y is
equal to x so it looks something like
that
so y
is equal to x or this is f of x equals
to x or y is equal to this f of x right
over there
now the derivative
actually let me just call that f x just
to make it not to confuse you so this
right over here is f of x is equal to x
that i graphed right over here y is
equal to f of x which is equal to x and
now let me graph the derivative let me
graph f prime of x that's saying it's 1
that's saying it's 1 for all x
regardless of what x is it's going to be
equal to 1.
is this consistent with what we know
about derivatives and slopes and all the
rest
well let's look at our function what is
the slope of the line or the tangent
line right at this point
well the slope of this right over here
this has slope one continuously or it
has a constant slope of one slope is
equal to one no matter what x is it's a
line there's a lot and for a line the
slope is constant so over here the slope
is indeed 1. if you go to this point
over here the slope is indeed 1. if you
go over here the slope is indeed 1. so
we got a pretty we got a pretty
valid response there now let's try
something where the slope might change
so let's say i have g of x
is equal to
x squared
the power rule tells us that g prime of
x would be equal to what
well n is equal to 2 so it's going to be
2 times x to the 2 minus 1 or it's going
to be equal to 2 x to the first power
it's going to be equal to 2 x so let's
see if this gives us if this makes
reasonable sense
and i'm going to try to graph this one a
little bit more precisely
graph it a little bit more precisely so
let's see
see how well i can graph it
how precisely i can graph it so this is
x-axis
y-axis let me mark some stuff off here
so this is one
two
three
four five this is one
two
three four
one
two
three four so g of x
g of x when x is zero it's zero when x
is 1 it is 1. when x is negative 1 it's
1 when x is 2 it is
4 so that puts us right over there 1 2 3
4. puts this right over there when x is
negative 2 you get to 4. it's a parabola
you've seen this for many years
so it looks something like it looks
something i put that point a little bit
too high it looks something like this
it looks something actually the last two
points i graphed a little bit weird so
this might be right over here
so it looks something like this
it looks something like that and then
when you come over here
it looks something like
it looks something like that it's
symmetric so i'm trying my best to draw
it reasonably so there you go that's the
graph of g of x g of x is equal to x
squared
now let's graph g prime of x or what the
power rule is telling us that g prime of
x is
so g prime of x is equal to 2 x so
that's just a line
goes through the origin of slope 2. so
it looks something like that when x is
equal to 1 y is equal to 2 when x is
equal to 2 y or g of x is equal to 4.
so it looks something something like
this
something
let me try my best to draw a straight
line it looks something like this
now does this make
does this make sense
well if you just eyeball it really fast
if you look at this point right over
here you want to think about the slope
of the tangent line
the slope i'm going to try my best to
draw let me do this in a color that's
more that pops out a little bit more so
the slope of the tangent line would look
something like this so it looks like it
has a reasonably high negative slope if
i were to yeah it's definitely a
negative slope and it's a pretty steep
negative slope well for x for x is equal
to 2
g prime of 2
g prime or sorry for x equal to negative
2 g prime of negative 2 g prime of
negative 2 is equal to 2 times negative
2 2 times negative 2 which is equal to
negative 4. so this is claiming that the
slope at this point so this right over
here is negative 4 saying that the slope
of this point is negative four m is
equal to negative four that looks about
right it's a very it's a fairly steep
negative slope
now what happens if you go
right over here when x is equal to zero
well our derivative if you say g prime
of 0 is telling us that the slope of our
original function g at x is equal to 0
is 2 times 0 is 0. well does that make
sense well if we go to our original
parabola it does indeed look set to make
sense that the slope of the tangent line
the tangent line looks something like
this we're at a minimum point we're at
the vertex the slope really does look to
be zero
and what if you go
what if you go right over here to x
equals two the slope of the tangent line
well over here the tangent line looks
something like this
looks like a fairly steep
positive slope what is our derivative
telling us based on the power rule it's
saying g prime
so this is essentially saying hey tell
me what the slope of the tangent line
for g is when x is equal to
2.
well we figured it out it's going to be
2 times x it's going to be 2 times 2
which is equal to 4. it's telling us
that the slope over here is 4. that the
slope and i'm just using m m is often
the letter used to denote slope they're
saying that the slope of the tangent
line there is 4 which seems completely
completely reasonable so i encourage you
to try this out yourself i encourage you
to
to try to estimate the slopes by
calculating by taking points closer and
closer around those points and you'll
see that the power rule really does give
you results that actually make sense